Wow which is love putter gwass wheeler
just hit three cards and this is what
you did no three hi guys I'm Sean
hi I'm Catalina today we'll be swapping
our favorite childhood board games so
the game go is such a classic like you
see in every manga and every anime and
every movie and it really tests your
wits and it really tests whether you're
younger or it's all about strategy who
can control the territory and it really
proves to the world how smart and how
intelligent how strategic you can be so
Sean I chose the game growth area for
you because it's a fun easy game very
simple to play I think you'll very much
enjoy it to me a note that here brings
back a lot of family memories we played
this side every get-together I have
actually have mine right here because
you always have to have one handy you
never know when you can play and for
tokens I have a bag of fecal ends beans
here that I usually play with but I've
literally the funny thing about it is
you can use anything as tokens I've
sometimes time I've even shots of
tequila okay so I'm super excited
I got loose any out right over here your
boy doesn't know horribly this game not
even close I thought your boy needs to
do some research so give me one second
because I've never heard of this at all
no fethiye is basically like a Mexican
bingo I kind of play bingo before we you
know growing up as an Asian American I
played bingo
Oh beforehand let's open up this bag
because I want to see like the cards and
everything aside inside there is the
cards that you pick and you say like El
Gallo which is rooster and then you also
have these tokens these tokens are kind
of used to mark you know were
whatever you get so like if someone said
oh soul I'll be like cool for the Toledo
soul whatever fun fact I want to see if
my roommate he's either gonna be like
astounding and amazing and I'm gonna be
shook or he's gonna be horrible and I
don't be like you know what save it's
all good rolling this together so from
the looks of it it looks like it's a
Chinese like checkers kind of thing or
like chess so this is what the board
looks like it's very like very fancy
minimalist so it's a two-player game
strategically placed pieces on different
points on the board where the lines
intersect to create territories by
surrounding vacant points or the
opponent's pieces alrighty I'm gonna
have to read that ganks I don't know
what that means I think in Spanish so a
lot of this is going in through my head
and going you know bring this you know
what I mean I have to see also fire
remember to play with me
Jasmine do you want to play this game
with meats
it's like checkers sounds good I'm with
my roommate right now so I'm excited
you've korean-american you just want his
face to be shell but he's really cute
but he's also married so y'all can't
date him sorry not sorry anyway we have
these cars already shuffled in so please
choose a card any card
King okay this is our bingo this is
Lydia so I mean what's your what's your
Spanish level all I want to say what
would you give yourself
very basic that is fine cuz me too oh we
have to give you these things as well
what color do you want do you want young
or actually be the rainbow layer just a
bunch of stuff oh so just to show y'all
I'm messy like this this is my mess of a
thing has it's super like clean and
organized like this
alrighty I'm the white stone she's the
black stone absolutely not okay you got
to see why gods are okay my turn
I have this one which is love Potter
wasps yes we enlarge it to three cards
and this is what he did the car do you
have got three oh yes I do finally your
boy got one okay my turn
take this miellyn about it cool
Yaya Dharma L of the novel Oh
Valiente which is work Oh looks like you
wanted
did I win yeah bleep oh wait did it
actually oh my god I got your class yeah
well that was easy
okay so guess who called me she got
questions gonna leave I got questions
like I watch like two tutorials like mmm
okay so like let me help break it down
for you like the objective is to
literally have more stones on the board
than your opponent that's it okay no
worries
now we're just gonna go around to let's
try this again
just put your son's down yeah nine by
nine here we go I'm gonna go right here
I'm gonna right here buddy love it
[Applause]
[Music]
48:46 and i have to be Wow okay so I'm
done it was actually a really really
really fun game I had a blast my
roommate but I definitely think it's a
great game with a great family game
especially when there's like multiple
people kids completed all simply elderly
people can play it's a great game just
to bring people together this experience
definitely let me be able to kind of
like embrace more facade X heritage that
I didn't know about and be would love to
know more about so I just finished
playing the game The Roommate Noboa that
was very difficult I think I was going
at the game differently I thought it was
just like try to capture all of the
other opponents stones but then after
talking to Sean and like when he was
when he literally told me the objective
of the game is just put all of your
stones on the board it made it so much
easier I want to get to be able to play
this whole thing instead of just like a
9 by 9 square actually this was Sean
also so maybe when we're allowed to go
back into the studio you and me baby
let's play
[Music]
[Music]
you